The Marvel Cinematic Universe is built on
the performances of its superstar actors.
So why did Chris Evans decide to quit?
Why can't Gwyneth Paltrow even remember the
movies she's already been in?
Keep watching to find out.
Yes, we know, Iron Man is dead.
But one thing we all know about comic book
movies is that nobody ever really stays dead.
Hey, if they brought Gamora back, they can
bring Tony Stark back, right?
Well, maybe.
In 2017, Robert Downey Jr. told news.com.au
that he didn't want to stay in the MCU much
longer, saying,
"I just want to hang up my jersey before it's
embarrassing."
And then the character got the biggest sendoff
ever in 2019's "Avengers: Endgame."
So it seemed like Downey was done for good.
Of his decision to leave, he told Howard Stern
in 2019,
"I didn't expect it to become what it became."
And also, I've always had other interests."
Despite this, Downey has still opened the
door for a possible return.
In February, 2021, GQ asked Downey if he would
ever return, and Downey said, quote, "Never
say never."
Please come back, Tony!
We love you 3000!
Chris Evans, much like pal Robert Downey Jr.,
appears to be done with his MCU character
Steve Rogers - a.k.a. Captain America - and
hasn't expressed much interest in showing
up in the MCU again after "Avengers: Endgame."
Steve's story rounded out so nicely and he
got the happy ending he wanted with Peggy
Carter, which was ultra-satisfying to Evans.
Despite that, he has still left the door open
for a return if the story is good enough.
In 2019, he said in a Variety conversation
with Scarlett Johansson,
"If you're going to revisit it, it can't be
a cash grab.
It can't be just because the audience wants
to be excited.
What are we revealing?
What are we adding to the story?
A lot of things would have to come together."
"Avengers…"
"...assemble!"
Someone who has not been shy about his desire
to stay in the MCU is Chris Hemsworth.
The actor has been playing Thor since 2011,
and if it were up to him, the ride would never
end.
Hemsworth is the only MCU star with a fourth
solo film in the works, and if he has anything
to say about it, it won't be his last.
In 2020 he told Elle Man that he's going to
keep going beyond the next Thor film, "Love
and Thunder."
"I'm not going into any retirement period.
Thor is far too young for that.
(He) is only 1500 years old!
It is definitely not a film that I say goodbye
to this brand."
Benedict Cumberbatch may not have as many
appearances under his belt as co-stars like
Robert Downey Jr. and Chris Hemsworth, but
his character Doctor Strange will play a major
part in the MCU going forward.
Thankfully, Cumberbatch is excited about getting
to continue to play Stephen Strange and wants
to keep doing so for a long time.
When speaking with Deadline back in 2018,
right after "Avengers: Infinity War" landed
in theaters, he was asked about playing Doctor
Strange in the future, to which he replied,
"Just try to stop me."
After helping to save the day in" Avengers:
Endgame," he’s returned in "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" and will do so again next year
in "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
— and hopefully long after.
Tom Holland came slinging into our lives as
Spider-Man in 2016's "Captain America: Civil
War," followed by two solo and two Avengers
films.
He completes the trilogy with "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," which debuted in the end of
2021.
It also ends his contract with Marvel Studios.
No need to worry though, as Holland is planning
on staying in the MCU for as long as they'll
let him.
Contracts are extended all the time, and the
actor is ready to sign on the line.
When catching up with Collider in early 2021,
he made sure to note that he wanted to don
the suit for as long as possible.
"I've always said to them if they want me
back I'll be there in a heartbeat.
I've loved every minute of being a part of
this amazing world.
It's changed my life for the better, I'm so
lucky to be here.
If they want me back I'll be there, if they
don't I will walk off into the sunset a very,
very happy person because it's been an amazing
journey."
Clint Barton has been with the MCU for quite
some time now and has outlasted countless
foes despite only using a bow and arrow.
Despite his lengthy stay with Marvel, he's
actually only had a major role in four films
and one small cameo in "Thor."
He also stars in his own Disney+ series, "Hawkeye,"
which debuted in November 2021, but Renner
might be done with his character after that.
Back in 2017, the actor was asked by the South
China Morning Post about a potential Hawkeye
movie.
While he expressed excitement and optimism
about the possibility, he said he would want
it to happen sooner rather than later because,
quote, "I don't want to be in my 50s in tights."
He's in his 50s now, so unless he's had a
change of heart, this might be it for Renner.
We first met Sam Wilson in "Captain America:
The Winter Soldier," and he instantly won
over our hearts thanks to a brilliant portrayal
by Anthony Mackie.
Sam has five major MCU appearances — in
addition to one small "Ant-Man" cameo — and
his own Disney+ series.
At the conclusion of that six episode run,
he takes up the mantle as the new Captain
America– so we’ll surely be seeing him
again soon.
In a digital press event for "Falcon and the
Winter Soldier," Mackie revealed that he would
love to appear somewhere in the upcoming Blade
film, even if it was just one line.
He also said he would love to pop up in the
She-Hulk series, which is set to land on Disney+
in 2022.
It’s been confirmed that Captain America
will return, with Mackie at the helm for the
foreseeable future.
Paul Bettany has portrayed Vision for three
MCU films and one Disney+ series, and fans
have fallen in love with the synthezoid.
Bettany has as well and is adamant about playing
the character for as long as Kevin Feige will
let him.
In a March 2021 interview with Esquire, when
Bettany was asked if he was going to play
Vision forever, he said,
"I love Vision.
Yes, I'm in."
We likely haven't seen the last of Vision
either, if the finale of "WandaVision" is
any indication.
White Vision is currently on the loose, with
the original's memories but not the same personality.
We'd be shocked to never see him again in
the MCU and are hoping Bettany really does
get to play the multi-dimensional character
again.
Colonel James Rhodes has been in the MCU since
Day 1, appearing in "Iron Man" as Tony Stark's
best friend.
The role was originally held by Terrence Howard,
but he left the franchise after a pay dispute.
Don Cheadle replaced the actor in "Iron Man
2," making him one of the longest-tenured
actors in the MCU.
Rhodey has mostly been a supporting character
for the last 11 years, but he will finally
get his chance to shine in his own Disney+
series, "Armor Wars," which is currently without
a release date.
During a press tour in 2020, Cheadle mentioned
wanting to see Rhodey do different things
in the future, verifying in the process that
he still wants to play the role.
"I'd really want to dig into him and maybe
even find something that felt closer to the
first Iron Man for who he was.
[...] I think they can go anywhere with him
now."
Just like Don Cheadle, Mark Ruffalo almost
wasn't in the MCU.
The Golden Globe winner took on the role of
Bruce Banner, a.k.a.
The Hulk, in 2012's "The Avengers," after
Edward Norton stepped away following 2008's
"The Incredible Hulk."
In a 2020 interview with Variety, Ruffalo
noted how shocked and lucky he is that he
gets to play the big green hero, and constantly
reminds himself of that when he's shooting
a Marvel film.
After admitting that he can sometimes get
annoyed on set when things are taking too
long to set up, he revealed that he'll say
to himself,
"Hey, remember you're not even supposed to
be here."
He also suggested that he'd love to play Banner
for as long as they'll let him.
And we know he's not done yet with the character
either, as he's confirmed to appear in the
Disney+ series "She-Hulk."
Another MCU star who doesn't plan on going
anywhere anytime soon is Star-Lord himself,
Chris Pratt.
The "Guardians of the Galaxy" star is slated
to appear in at least two more MCU films that
we know of, "Thor: Love and Thunder" in 2022
and "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" in 2023.
We don't know how many films he's under contract
for, but that doesn't seem to matter anyway.
He told Slashfilm in 2017,
"I'll tell you, as much as I love Marvel,
it doesn't matter how many I have contracted
because I'm going to continue to work with
them.
[...] I love working with them and I'm going
to continue to work with them whether they
like it or not.
Even if they write me out, I'm going to show
up on set and be like, 'Hey, man!'
They're done.
They don't get to shake me."
When it comes to "most appearances in MCU
films," you can put Gwyneth Paltrow toward
the top of the list with seven.
Pepper Potts has been in every Iron Man film,
as well as "Spider-Man: Homecoming" and three
out of four Avengers flicks, but had relatively
minor roles for her last several appearances.
It turns out this is just how she likes it.
She isn't too crazy about spending a lot of
time on movie sets anymore.
When it comes to the MCU, however, Paltrow
said she would be happy to show up to work
on a future project, just as long as it only
took a few days.
Speaking with People in early 2021, the actress
said she would be open to returning to the
MCU, if it wasn't anything big.
"I think if it was a small part that I could
do in like a day or two."
Not that she'll remember it anyway.
"Spiderman?"
"Yeah, we were in Spiderman together.
Remember we were in Spiderman?"
"We weren't in Spiderman!"
"Yes we were."
One of the newer heroes in the MCU, Valkyrie,
has proven herself a force to be reckoned
with.
With just two Marvel Studios films under her
belt, actress Tessa Thompson has a lot she
wants to prove in the Marvel franchise.
She will appear in the fourth Thor flick due
out in 2022, but she wants to stick around
as long as possible to hopefully land in an
all-female team-up adventure.
When she was just starting out with the MCU
in 2017, Thompson said at a press event that
she asked Kevin Feige about making an all-female
movie at the studio, and he apparently told
her yes.
It's now four years later and we still have
no confirmation of one, but Thompson seems
like she wants to stick with the MCU until
it happens.
She told CinemaBlend in 2019,
"There's so many incredible, talented women
in the MCU that I just want to work with selfishly."
Keep fighting the good fight, Valkyrie, because
we'd all love to see it too.
No one has more appearances in the MCU than
Mr. Samuel L. Jackson.
The legendary actor appeared in the first
"Iron Man" film's end credits and has been
popping up in movie after movie ever since.
Jackson has shown up in 11 of 23 MCU films
— a healthy mix of supporting roles and
cameos.
One of the older actors in the MCU, Jackson
isn't going to let age affect him moving forward.
When speaking with The Hollywood Reporter
in 2019, Jackson said he would be happy to
play Nick Fury in his 80s, saying,
"I could be the Alec Guinness of Marvel movies."
He isn't going anywhere either, as he will
also be getting his own Disney+ series – "Secret
Invasion" – but whether he shows up in the
MCU anywhere else remains to be seen.
It would be hard to imagine a world where
Fury didn't pop up in someone's post-credits
scene every now and again.
"How I Met Your Mother" alum Cobie Smulders
joined the MCU in 2012 for "The Avengers"
as Nick Fury's right hand agent, and has since
popped up in five more MCU films.
But while she doesn't have the same MCU resume
as other actors on our list, she definitely
has the same amount of passion as they do.
When asked by The Hollywood Reporter in 2019
if she'd want to play Agent Maria Hill for
the rest of her life, the actress said,
"I would love to!
[...] I love being a part of the world of
Marvel.
It's a magical, wonderful place filled with
only nice, caring, considerate, creative people."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.